you say and i i don't say this uh often
to uh other men on the show great hair
thank you sir thank you it doesn't come
up a lot yeah yeah really thank you it
means a lot coming from you you are the
you are the king of hair you have the
only remaining pompadour in the business
so it is true between no one is you no
one has the nerve to sport this thing
anymore no no but they
all right yeah all right yes yeah so
that i'm the only black comic with the
perm so between the two of us we've got
the niche industry already hooked up uh
let me also ask about the the jewelry i
i this this
this is nice that's jewelry yeah i'm
becoming the new liberace it appears
everybody wants to everybody wants to
talk about the jewelry i just need the
motivation i need to look down and see
i'm doing something to keep me uh
excited about things right right right
so this you look down you see like oh
things are good yes things are good
don't worry about the economy the
recession the mortgage
prices just ignore all that
that's a great message for everyone i
think
now let's talk about this i know that we
all have heroes in show business
one of your all-time heroes i'm told is
prince and you got to meet him fairly
recently how did that go it was it was
wonderful he uh was
all the things i thought he was going to
be he was uh
he's a genius and smart and i think he's
david blaine secretly he's like david
you think he's a magician i think he is
i was talking to him and he was like uh
would you care for some tea and i was
like yeah of course i and he was gone he
was just he was already gone then he
came back from another part of the room
with like a tray with 13 tees on it was
right
it was it was amazing yeah he uh yeah
he's like he's very mysterious he loves
to have all this mystery and you don't
know where he's going what he's doing
what he's talking about half the time no
no and he'll wear pumps and be looking
at you like there's nothing wrong
he commits so much to wearing pumps that
it works yes it makes you think about it
like could i get away with it on the
basketball court maybe one time now
okay are you are you taller than prince
uh how does that work out he's cheating
he's got pumps on okay
can't live up with that
i'm gonna say i'm taller just cause he's
not here right yeah that'll work
here suddenly right now
13.
[Laughter]
okay uh what's let's talk about the
height issue
did your height affect you do you think
growing up did it influence you know
your life your comedy i i think so it
made me uh very cynical and bitter uh
i i had heard about a growth spurt and
it was like the loch ness legend like
everybody gets a growth spurt and it's
gonna happen and just wait it's gonna be
one summer and everything's gonna change
and i'm grown now and i'm still waiting
you still waiting summer to come you're
still waiting on this growth first yes
it could happen you know good maybe i'm
just late i'm willing to wait it's gonna
happen like that uh
do you think uh that this affected your
relationship with women your your
success with women uh when um it made me
try really hard because women weren't
tall dark and handsome and i wasn't able
to fulfill any of those so i
when i got a woman i really tried hard
you know i think short guys make better
lovers just because once we get on we
don't want to get off
did you
yeah did you okay uh
all these images are going to no that
came out right now off me not yet uh
did you ever uh okay do you ever date a
much taller woman
yeah yeah i dated uh a wnba player once
she was six three six three yeah and i
thought it was gonna be
i don't know it was just weird like
because i was proud that it didn't
matter in the relationship but it's
still like your whole you're a kid
holding your mom's hand with me
[Applause]
you'll lift me up and kiss me
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah uh now you've uh
i i guess you have a bunch of friends
who are
rap stars rappers is that right
and and you maintain you know comedians
and you know rappers you think that
rappers
are funnier than comedians is that true
i'm saying some of these rap guys are
just hilarious like i didn't i didn't
understand that they were that funny
like snoop is just really hilarious
he's doing all these things he's he's
got two tv shows he's doing a movie he's
got three albums he's coaching football
he's doing a show about being a father
and you hear he's high and you're like i
can't get out of the room if i'm high
yeah
remarkable man yeah he really he really
is but yeah the rap world has just been
amazingly hilarious to find out how many
funny guys are out there yeah i can well
and else they have their own language
and there's their way of living and they
just this bravado and it works you know
all about it you're there with us at the
parties
it's true yeah i'm the i'm a fixture at
every rat party
hiya fellas how's it going
ladies and gentlemen the pompadour yeah
wow where's the
fondue i'll put on a monkey's album
uh not a negro function without fondue
that's for sure
uh
you know we've been talking about uh
this a lot of things here and
one of the things that i wanted to
mention is that you have your own
clothing line this is this is real right
you're coming out with your own clothing
line yeah i want to make sure i get to
this before we go tell us about the
clothing line uh it's called secret pimp
society uh
because you know everybody's not able
and uh it's a good thing to be able to
find somewhere where you can just find
uh wonderful fly clothes that nobody
else is gonna have on but you and that
uh that becomes important and this works
for everybody with this
work for me yeah oh are you kidding that
you just started your channel it looks
like you just changed into it right now
you are the secret pimp society right
now
i'm the pimp that's heavily more into
the finance side yes yes
no no no this is not looking good this
quarter
yeah yeah uh well let me mention this a
few things american hustle is now
available on dvd uh cat's gonna be at
the gibson amphitheater in los angeles
june 26 27-28 as part of the it's pimpin
pimpin tour exactly
i'm gonna come in right in the middle
and serve fondue that's gonna be
really big uh you are
very funny and great to talk to please
come back soon and congratulations on
your success
pat williams
we'll be back with bryce stick around